si yo muy buenos días para todos ustedes
soy puesta un poquito la agitación en
estos momentos porque se espera que el
rey carlos hetero salga dentro de pocos
instantes desde aquí desde balmoral
donde pasó la noche junto con su esposa
la reina consorte y de aquí pues irá
hasta abril y na es ahí está el
aeropuerto justamente para ese viaje que
lo lleve de nuevo a la ciudad de londres
para la conversación un poco de
agitación había unas barreras de
seguridad aquí que las han quitado
precisamente para que puedan pasar los
automóviles pero en medio de todo esto
siguen llegando las personas de todas
las vecinas aquí de balmoral de aberin
ser también que vienen como les venía
diciendo a lo largo de toda esta mañana
incluso desde muy temprano esta
madrugada para traer flores para dejar
mensajes para tener unos momentos unos
instantes de recogimiento hemos visto
personas bastante emocionadas con
muchísimas lágrimas en los ojos muy
tristes por el fallecimiento de la reina
y bueno como les decía muchísima
agitación aquí precisamente por eso así
como muchísimos medios munich acción
vinimos a cubrir todo lo que esté
sucediendo aquí en navalmoral por ahora
pues el féretro de la reina permanece en
una sala principal aquí de este castillo
y nos espera sino hasta el día domingo
debería llegar a edimburgo en una larga
procesión desde aquí hasta hasta la
capital escocesa
gracias natalia y una pregunta adicional
y es luego que se espera que pase con el
féretro y cómo podría ser transportado
hasta londres
bueno pues una vez que esté allí en
escocia perdón en edimburgo estará en el
hollywood de pda's en el palacio de
holyrood y allí estará en la sala del
trono se llama y estará por un tiempo el
féretro la idea es dar también la
posibilidad a las personas que puedan
digamos durante 24 horas venir a
despedirse de la reina justamente esto
será normalmente el día domingo habrá un
servicio en la catedral descendidos allí
estará la familia real presente en este
servicio y se espera como decía 24 horas
normalmente sobre el día lunes estaría
viajando en la féretro hasta londres al
principio lo que se entendía en este
plano unicornio era que este
desplazamiento se hiciera en x 30 y sin
embargo ha cambiado un poco los planes y
sería normalmente por avión ahora este
desplazamiento pero que saber que
finalmente justamente ahora cuando el
rey a carlos tercero llegue a londres
pues va a finalmente pues ya afirmaría
digamos a dar todo su acuerdo a todo lo
que se tiene planeado para estos
funerales era con el conde de norfolk
con quien hablará de los detalles de
todo lo que tenga que ver con el funeral